I think when you when you when you when
you're on the side of the road and
you're [ __ ]
you treated worse than a pedophile who's
like caught in a schoolyard
it really it when you were treated like
you are when you're on the side of the
road you were at your most vulnerable
and helpless yep when you were in this
Long Island Mafia owned tow truck
company's own the parkways right so Oh
Triple A will tell you they're like we
don't we'll reimburse you but we don't
even go on the northern stay don't even
do that so you call Johnny and Vinny's
uh removal yeah and Johnny's towing and
they'll hook you up and some guy pulls
up he's a guy you dawn my friend let me
his car wants a lot of people lend me
their cars their homes things like that
right and I expect the things you lend
me to be in good condition mm-hmm that's
the reality
yeah who are lending me Yeah right car
this [ __ ] lend it to me and the thing
breaks down and I call him up and I
screaming them I go in now when this
happens to you do you look at the
girlfriend do you start going wild I
just
I mean well though cuz she would freak
out right so if I like started like
complaining too much being myself alone
oh my god it's [ __ ] yeah it's over
I'm just screaming at the tow truck
driver I'm screaming at the mechanics
yeah I'm gonna pretend that they [ __ ]
with it and I know you're up to
something and chilly with her around I
have to be like diplomatic a little bit
I have to pretend to know anything about
cars yeah radiator this I just I don't
know I try to get in with the tow truck
people I go let's I'll get in on a scam
I'll break more of the car just cut me
in tell me what I need to do once it
gets to that level